فري ستايل فوتبول او كره القدم استعراضيه
فنان يحتاج لمهاره عاليه والكثير من
التدريب والجهد صابر محمد العوض شاب
سوداني اتقن هذه الرياضه رغم ظروفي اعاقته
في مونديال كاس العالم ابهر الكثيرين
بمهاراته النادره هناء شادته من الجماهير
هناك وعلى صفحته على مواقع التواصل له
جمهور بالالاف يدعمونه ويشجعونه عيشقه
لكره القدم دفعه للاصرار على ممارستها وهو
في سن صغيره واحلام هو ان يصبح نجما
عالميا وان يكون مثالا يحتذى به لذوي
الايمان
[موسيقى]
حدثنا اول شيء عن مجيئك للدوحه
كيف حضرت قطعت الاف الكيلومترات انت من
محافظه مدني في السودان
ووصلت الى الدوحه ايوه والله انا يعني كان
من زمان حلمي انه احضر كاس العالم لما كاس
العالم في روسيا انا حلمي يحضر كاس العالم
في الدوحه فبعد الشهره فقلت يمكن تجيني
دعوه احضر كاس العالم فلما كاس العالم قرب
حبي كره القدم
تحس انك مشهور اكثر في همم لما كنت في
السودان ولا الاجواء المونديال هنا
والجمهور اداك شهر اكثر برشلونه
كيف حبيت كره القدم رغم الظروف اللي
تعلمينها يعني صعبه يعني تحتاج الكنترول
واستقبال وحركه ايوه انا اصلا يعني في
المشي العادي يكون تحتاج لتوازن يعني في
الحركه انا كنت ما متوازيه فلما يعني انت
انسان فلازم نقاط ضحك على سبب نجاحك
فاهمين هذه وانطلقته
يعني فديت كره القدم بمعانه كبيره جدا
صعوبات كثيره
في الاخر يعني انت قلت للرياضه الفايبر
[موسيقى]
وما في حدا يضربك على رجلك
طيب اعطيني مواقفك كيف الناس بتطلبك
المشهور يلا
[موسيقى]
الله الله يا صابر
الله